foreign
every time you see a space movie or
something and people are in space
they're always weightless you ever
notice that that's true
um and you know that because they're
um well if your Sandra Bullock your hair
is like afro okay you got a little space
afro going on except she didn't exactly
in the movie Gravity her bangs always
seem to know which way down was even
everything else is floating in the
capsule so so it leaves people thinking
that space equals no gravity right at
least people thinking that like you just
go up into space and all of a sudden
you're weightless and weightlessness is
a very special condition oh that for
which you do not have to be in space to
achieve so I just want to just tease
this out of people's understanding
misunderstandings I'm not gonna push
back on you
I'm just gonna say that maybe your
people have something to do with this
here's why whenever you see people you
know in space in the space station
whatever they always say they're in zero
g well we think zero g means zero
gravity that's what we're going to think
correct it is zero g because there's no
net gravitational force acting on them
okay no net grab there's important
distinction here and I don't want to be
too pedantic semantic about it yeah but
but okay
um if you are in orbit around Earth okay
you are Falling Towards Earth we did a
whole explainer on this yes we did how
do you achieve orbit all right and talk
about Newton and shooting The Cannonball
I wanted the Cannonball and you duck and
all of that so we go back we'll put a
link to that previous one so here's my
point let's say
you are on Route towards the moon okay
okay
do you know how we do that how does NASA
do that well they're going to worry
about it then they do a tli translunar
injection with a leave Earth orbit right
aim towards where the moon will be when
they when they get there okay nice all
right so at that point they shut off
their engines
if you're in space and your engines are
shut off
you are falling
towards whatever is pulling you wherever
it is right
smart because and I learned this from an
explainer that we did that's why you
need to listen to the explainers people
if you will be falling to whatever pulls
you no matter where that is unless you
happen to be in a LaGrange point oh out
this is what I love this job because I
didn't know that like however whenever I
didn't know it I didn't know it okay so
the five of them and so we don't have to
get into that just now but okay all I'm
saying is if you are coasting then you
are Falling Towards where whatever is
pulling you at that point right okay you
will be weightless as long as you are
coasting right okay no matter what okay
and so here's what will happen they have
transluter injection which is enough
speed
to make it to the one of the LaGrange
points between Earth and the Moon
that's called L1 at that point the
Earth's pull towards Earth equals the
moon pulled towards towards the Moon
that's a balance point okay so now if I
have enough energy to cross that point
now I will guarantee to fall towards the
most the moon exactly now if I don't
have enough speed to reach that point
guess what happened
the Earth says where are you going yeah
come on back what the hell you think you
do
you're trying to sneak out on me get
your ass back there get your ass back
here right now so if you don't make it
to that first lagrangea point you will
fall back to Earth exactly okay but that
entire time you're still just falling
okay as you're leaving Earth you're
falling
Earth's gravity is pulling back on you
slowing you down but you're in free fall
even though you're leaving Earth and
you're free fall when you turn around in
your free fall when you come back you're
weightless that entire time okay if you
cross the boundary Point you're
weightless Crossing it you're weightless
the whole time okay you are weightless
until
you hit the moon
then you are one-sixth Earth gravity
okay on the moon after you Collide all
right or if you turn on your engines
okay if you turn on your rocket engines
anywhere in space okay when you were
otherwise just coasting right you will
have
what is effectively a gravitational
field inside your rocket
all right because the Rockets will be
accelerating the spaceship gotcha okay
it'll be accelerating right so so what's
a good way to show that
um
uh all right so how about this so we're
in a rocket sort of headed towards Mars
let's say okay we're standing on the
bottom of the rocket okay okay so the
bottom the trail end of this thing
headed towards more but we're weightless
we're weightless but we're glued to the
bottom and I toss you something it'll
just go straight towards you right okay
because everything is weightless
everything nothing's falling it'll just
go straight towards you okay now watch
I now ignite the Rockets
though the moment I toss the object
right
the rocket is going at a particular
speed the instant I let go of the object
and the rocket is going faster in the
next instant and still faster in the
instant after that so the object will
look like it'll fall towards the floor
of the rocket towards the back which is
our floor which is correct it'll look
like it's Falling Towards the rocket
towards the bottom of the rocket whereas
it's the bottom of the rocket
accelerating towards the object right
Einstein figured out that if you're in a
rocket
you cannot know the difference
between the rocket accelerating through
space and whether the rocket is sitting
there on Earth right because the rocket
is creating an artificial gravity
correct by having by having the
acceleration now I've managed to catch
in a couple of episodes of the expanse I
love that show this is a one of the
favorite shows of one of our
um our lead producers and writers Lynn
Lindsay Walker they want you to cut they
wanted you to come on the um their
podcast
they have a big podcast that was how do
you know they wanted me to come up this
is the first time you're telling me this
I am for I should have probably told you
that right
anyway the expanse is like there's the
the folks from Mars and then the
asteroid belt then the Earth Federation
and of course there's Wars and things
and fighting and bad people all right
point is when they put on their Rockets
there's acceleration inside the rocket
that's right
there's basically they have a way to
attach to the
surfaces when they are in zero g and
they make sure you know that so they're
not playing loosey-goosey with the laws
they wear gravity boots especially
batteries but in other conditions and
other circumstances and I haven't seen
all seasons but the few I've seen
they're thinking about this they play
they play it straight yeah they play it
straight and when they're when it's
accelerating there is an effective field
of gravity in the ship and the higher
that acceleration is the higher that
gravity will feel okay unlike the film
what's the one where they had Moon
Pirates at Astra oh yes
in Ad Astra they're they're in Rockets
accelerating to the moon so it takes
faster than three days to get there
right and in the accelerating Rockets
everybody's weightless
yes that's correct no that's not how
that works so great if you want to get
to the moon in a few hours everybody's
sitting in the chair feeling this
gravity minus well you might as well be
on a 737 thank you thank you New York
City thank you because it's the same
thing same thing what a great catch
because I now remember that but that uh
I didn't even catch that I didn't even
make that connection they all float
around waitlist and you see the Rockets
firing in the back it's not how that
works so the difference between 737 is
in the 737 you still feel Earth's
gravity down because you're not in orbit
and you're not in free fall right that's
why balloons if you're floating but you
still have if you put a scale under your
feet you're gonna still weigh as much as
you do on earth right it's not in free
fall right okay right it's all about
Free Fall now if now if I put you in an
elevator cut the cable right you're in
free fall right so you're gonna fall and
the and the and the chalk that you're
holding is falling or the ball and
everything's falling and it looks like
it's flow loading in front of your face
so you could let go of your drink your
little soda can while you're falling in
the elevator and it would just stay
right there right with you correct
correct and you want to know a really
cool experiment okay you could do this
at home but we'll do it in the elevator
first because these are experiments you
do in the elevator before you die at the
bottom okay so this is but it's for
science well we might as well get those
experiments out of the way I mean
if you're gonna die let it not be in
vain okay exactly uh when the elevator
hits the bottom so if you if you if you
have one of these big gulps okay so it's
a huge container and you're sitting
there and the elevator is on the you
know 100th floor and you puncture a hole
in the side of your your big gulp vessel
okay so what's gonna happen
well it should start you know sprinkling
out it was a Sprinkle it's a nice hole
it'll stream out it'll have a nice Arc
as it goes down okay it's coming out
because it feels pressure from the
weight of the water above it above the
hole right I go back to our water towers
yeah if you want to know about the
weight of water
so and by the way if you put multiple
holes the one at the bottom will make a
longer stream than the ones that are
above it because it's under higher
pressure right okay you have a long
stream and middle stream and a little
stream okay if you can punch the three
holes in it simultaneously right that's
the weight of the water putting pressure
to have the water exit the hole so now
cut the cable okay you fall the cup
Falls this the soda Falls
everything is falling and everything is
in free fall and everything is
weightless you are in zero g if you are
in zero g
the water is no longer Under Pressure
pressure because the water above it
doesn't weigh anything right and if the
water above it doesn't weigh anything
there is no pressure for the water to
come out the hole
the water does not know to exit the hole
and all three of those spillages cuts
off instantly
nice for the entire Journey
until you die at the bottom right in
which case you just got a little a
bigger mess on the floor than you have
to worry about with a big gulp you know
believe me okay so now
the way to do this is go get a Big Gulp
right ready here's what you do puncture
three holes in it three vertical holes
and then put tape one piece of tape over
it okay now fill it up
with some liquid that doesn't make a
mess
now stand up on some ladder all right or
above some stairs or something right now
hold it up high and film this
film this okay okay take the tape
quickly remove it off you'll see the
three streams and then let it go
and all three streams will just stop
like they were just cut off because
while the cup is falling it is
weightless and it'll continue that way
until it hits the ground
very cool very cool in fact do it and
put your video in the in the in the
thread below do it yeah go ahead
do it post it post it uh please post it
if it didn't work
uh it will work because it's physics no
I'm gonna say if it didn't work we know
you messed something up real bad or
you're not of this planet of this
universe
are you not here
so anyhow if you are accelerating this
is what happens and by the way NASA
calls it microgravity to this day I do
not understand why or rather I'll make a
stronger statement they have misnamed it
by calling it microgravity okay gravity
is identically zero on an orbiting
spacecraft they're worried because we're
still in Earth's gravitational field
right okay so I think they're worried
that that might confuse people so that's
why you say zero g
because that's a that's a force zero
G-Force that's a it is a zero g
zero g and world to Cronkite in the
1960s when we when when Apollo was eight
Pauline Apollo eight or ten when we
first went to the moon before the
astronauts uh landed
this one of his broadcasts said um as a
good ride 4 45 this afternoon the
astronauts have left the gravitational
pull of the Earth
it's like and then he then he had to say
this Justin I'm an idiot
I've just been told that I'm a complete
mask because that's not true because
they're on route to the Moon which last
we checked is held to Earth by Earth's
gravity right so uh what he meant there
was that it crossed from Earth's
influence to the moon's influence he
crossed one of the LaGrange points right
so he lost an edge a learning
opportunity for the audience and so yeah
there's no micro nothing okay it is zero
freaking G Paris there you go
this was fun
um
this was great all right and this thing
with the acceleration and Earth's
gravity uh the that's called to Einstein
the equivalence principle and it's one
of the deepest I most brilliant ideas
ever advanced in the history of physics
the equivalence principle right that
gravitational acceleration is not only
equivalent it is indistinguishable
from acceleration by Rockets or anything
else that would move you through space
if you did that within a in a box with
no windows right you would not be able
to tell them correct look at that am I
on Earth or am I accelerating through
space at 1G you would not know science
you gotta love it and just a few days
ago I did a fast calculation if you
accelerate it 1G it'll take you about 10
months I think I have to redo it to get
precise for about 10 months to reach the
speed of light
and one last thing the units of
acceleration that's why they have this
weird construct okay so the acceleration
of gravity is 32 feet per second per
second
that is those are units what does that
mean per second what does that mean and
it's actually per second squared if you
did it out what that means is for every
second
you increase your speed by 32 feet per
second right
so how fast are you going after two
seconds
64 feet how fast are you going after
three seconds
oh per second no 96. I'm sorry 96 feet
oh no it's 32 not 64. 32 right right
okay that's another 32. another 32. so
for every second every second it's
another 32. and it's we'll never stop
all right never stop well don't stop
until you hit oh wait now you just made
me think of the expanse again I just got
something that they do in that well they
do when they're approaching a planet
even though they're really far away from
the planet the Rockets are firing in the
opposite direction yes
yes yes
yes otherwise they'll just free fall
down they'll free fall down and they'll
and they'll crash land so it's right so
you have to so you turn around the
Rockets slow you down that will give you
an acceleration by the way okay it'll
give you so all of a sudden they'll have
some kind of uh g-forces operating on
them and they can take that all the way
in if they want yeah yeah but it it
looks weird because they're like nowhere
near the planet but yet they're still
firing retro Rockets well yeah because
they've been speeding up so fast that
whole way Falling Towards them falling
across the planet they have to do that
in in order to put on the brakes in fact
one of the ideas of how to get to Mars
without being zero g for nine months is
you accelerate at 1G
halfway to Mars right then you turn
around and decelerate at 1G to March and
so you're in Earth's gravity 1G the
entire trip awesome
that's how you do that and then you
don't need the medical
examiner right looking at your or
whoever they are you know some things
happen to his bone density of what it is
there's no bone density issue exactly
yeah yeah
all right that's more just zero g talk
oh that was great all right Chuck love
it Colony quits there this has been
another explainer from StarTalk thank
Chuck always for being there always a
pleasure as always keep looking up
[Music]